naturally I'm bummed dazzle doesn't come
back back neither like a visible and I
see with clarity
my my name is Jerry Tom but I've been
telling you how accountability I'll
triple a given a pedigree to meet in a
pleasure my best piece according to
wartime jernard the move of furniture
[Music]
yo man how are you how are you good real
pleasure how Thanks I appreciate your
thought and I try really trying to full
screen for this one hey I've got a quick
business thing for you on good slightly
here's the pedestal how it is is pretty
called switches and in the five ten
minutes yoga at the beginning tenders
recipe on forty minutes in between in
forty minutes you do twenty different
exercises each one for two minutes and
then I yelled switch are you mention not
yes that is awesome he's been coming to
the classes and fries or crazy people
against you once you guys take over some
logistically incapable and work with
Andy maybe two or three weeks will go
because I know a lot of travel coming up
really fast yeah I could tie Alex like I
said get everybody who's been talking
[ __ ] see where everybody's at various
saying boys been to business and you
always try to come up with potential for
to the military I went to college
finished military and I rewrite the
election program new recruits coming in
and then I always recorded the sports
I'm into Beirut
la i working industry day trying to
listen to because she was in Jurassic
Park Channel the dinosaurs for the
seminar school alright let's do this
then within the day I'm looking forward
seeing I'll sail away job looked after
it my possible
Kirk cooked pleasure I yes thank you how
are you ok for you Andrew Volpe 1 July
approved for library I live on the
record I'm Gary Vaynerchuk the CEO Bayer
media there's no concern about the fact
that a lot of people do want to work and
play at the same time everyone sensor
about the work-life balance among us
when we're working harder than we did
our world ended at 6 p.m. or at home nor
those working at 7 p.m. 8 p.m. 9 p.m.
and having all of the other luxuries
that are going to surround this entire
process is it very big deal to me the
idea that an employee that's hustling a
millennial who works can go at 7:30 to
one of the best restaurant tours in the
world and sit there and work is it a
very poor environment when you look at
the Facebook's in the googles of the
world the way they really create their
campuses are really intended to maximize
results for me Lyn Armenia is not of the
size of Facebook Google Weber is sa P
and Boston Consulting lore'l and coach
and Time Warner I mean we're talking
about the biggest companies of the world
that have these campuses well for me
Hudson Yards becomes a campus we don't
own all of it it's not all of ours but
in the collective I now can check off
all the boxes that allows me to be
competitive to get the best talent in
the world and to me when I think about
that that's the punchline when anybody
watching right now and that's the
punchline if you're a CFO CEO board
member decision maker that's the
punchline who you think is competing
with how are you going to win it's a
talent game I'm pledging to my sacred
for sale
my name is Andy cranek I'm brand
director for the man garyvee I've worked
for Gary for over three years now I woke
up one morning I saw Gary tweet what can
I do for you and I've clicked on the
tweet and saw people responding and
someone said I'm hungry and Gary had
said give me your phone number I'm gonna
send you a cheeseburger like 10 minutes
later this guy tweeted back a photo that
a cheeseburger had arrived at his house
like damn this guy Gary is like really
doing these things so I immediately just
tweeted back at him a chance to work for
free he responded right back
details question mark and I responded
I'm just looking for an opportunity to
prove myself and I'm going to do it free
so we and should also feel going forward
completely answers we have that
so we're basically I guess those 150 so
we do have a function one Episode five
specialty so there's like five division
and just not getting as much output as I
want and everything so I want to I want
to make sure I talk to both of you about
what the current plan is and what some
of the tweaks that I had and malleable
it one night I was laying in bed at
midnight I see an email come in it says
from Gary Vaynerchuk it said where can
you live how little are you willing to
work for I responded I come if in New
York City and I said I could work three
key CC mate who was his assistant at the
time and said Nate I like this kid maybe
interns for the book I interned for Gary
for five months so I joined a team full
time about two years ago and then I've
now since become his brand director for
about a year and a half two years and
it's quite the ride but stuff like the
French thing if we can get 1015 videos
in French that having to be abused
hold on Andy said I know you doing all
the international stuff with captioning
what language are we missing so I can I
can tag you Arabic translators the
punchline is my videos translate in
Arabic who want that internship all
right what's your
with your intro or what you can just
inspired clack clack what it look at
what you decided you started that if you
wanted to plug his oh yeah although zero
person I know that that's the one I use
for business anyway talked all yeah one
just sort like this what is alright we
have a running joke that a d-roc does
everything on his team and do rocks
amazing and he's a very very skilled and
we love him very much but there's a lot
more to the man that scary be that's
helping him run his day-to-day than just
David Rock such as Tyler Bevin who edits
most of the daily visas that you've been
Cinque Tyler Schmidt who handles all his
meetings his emails his inbox and also
he has a business development guy Alex
Eastman he has a designer he has myself
he has Elliot who helps with Instagram
he has a lot of amazing players in when
you have nine people trying to work on
one brand and that one brand is a person
how can we coalesce and come together
and support the initiatives that Gary
wants so things we want to grab you I
think it stems from a little bit of what
we talked about last week over you know
but I think the larger question is that
the three of us kind of end up for a
storm and commercial
is a lot about internal communication in
flash culture and the question was where
and how much do you want to be involved
in things that we create and then I
think it really got hiding me because we
will talk about us we get a lot of tests
a lot of what Johan accessor right now
the most because I think that's the
thing that's most probably populated to
our minds is which is I just don't think
on is aligned with what is the obvious
way to do this and I think that we
should all get aligned I think it's a
DNA thing for anybody anybody that you
know I think everything has rewards and
everything has pros and cons every
situation I think it's very imperative
game of like self awareness and
understanding you know your your
appetite for feedback and your own self
awareness and empathy about is
completely mapped to the upside of how
much you can put yourself out there
on so what religious heaven is I tried
like three different times to say what's
the most important thing I've learned
from Garrett is it's like speed it's
work ethic Gary really does work fifteen
eighteen hours a day which is insane and
he does Trump speed over everything else
just fast as possible the world's moving
and we're trying to keep up with it but
really is empathy
Gary's intuition and the way he
understands people and can relate to
them is why we're successful oh yeah I
don't how much York I on my own Bureau
you have this high caste likes you I
kind of have like multiple revenue
streams which i think is the way to go
two years ago only I was working a
regular nine-to-five job and then I was
working on my site hotel which is my
blog and a few other things and now I'm
a digital nomad doing my own thing and
traveling and that yeah
I know a thesis pelvic balancing at all
but how do I make sure that I was doing
the same amount of love to all my
different little progress adventures by
not quibbling yourself and thinking that
you need to give the same amount of love
at all times all these people are too
worried about the micro and they think
like every if you have four projects you
have to give them all 25% every single
day the reality is I'm just sitting here
right now with my team something's you
know right now Wine Library is getting
zero love right right you know you know
sometimes my personal brand is getting
love sometimes vaynermedia's getting
love I think it's you need to be careful
I'm not trying to be balanced at all
times you just need to be balanced in
the macro or you need to map to the
ambition that you have for it so you
know it's four different projects if you
gave them a percentage of value to you
or upside to you or how much you like
them or how big you think they can be
you need to map your energy that way so
if you think this one thing the blogging
is 80% of your upside when we need to be
mapping 80% of your energy and the
others might be five five and ten he
finishes much attitude before I'm done
speaking and he does it you can deploy
empathy in every way whether it's trying
to help your coworker trying to
understand where they're coming from or
trying to make a million dollars on a
business pitch if you can put yourself
in that other person's shoes the least I
can put myself out there so much as I'm
so in a great spot on those pillars and
that's a the ultimate blessing of life
and a very empathetic that most people
don't come with that level of balance of
ego and humility and I think that's what
it takes
however balanced you are with ego and
humility will play out itself in the
public eye and so I think that's why
I've been able to navigate because I
think I'm the best but I think I mean
nothing and I'm just empathetic to
people's feedback I'm also self-aware
like I curse I'm quite confident in the
[ __ ] I talk about which will turn people
off especially if they have no context I
don't expect them to have context people
always come up to me and say oh sorry I
didn't know who you were I was like
bouncing around with ninety nine point
nine to five the world doesn't know who
I am so I think I think the answer to
that question I think much to wipe I
have a good feel of gaga and like
no Herbeck foreign people around her
like she's in a good spot she can handle
that pretty well because she's internal
and I think if you have your self-worth
wrapped up in others opinions it's a
very difficult game to play or you play
it to the level of where your appetite
goes it's too many people [ __ ]
themselves on finding that balance and
they're doing it in a micro instead of a
macro yeah I'm trying to think of them
as like my kids and give them the female
model love but maybe not no nobody ever
gives their kids insane amount of love
in a micro it's just not the way it
happens and even in a macro it's
probably inconceivable and so you know
sometimes you have to worry about the
kid that's got an issue or sometimes you
have to worry about the kid that's
excelling and so that's just the way it
works and the middle kid never gets any
love I mean the whole thing I go to
moments where it's better and it's worse
than it's good like again I do think
everybody's overthinking the day-to-day
you need to think of this in years 10
instead of days
[Music]
[Music]